kenny s is the op
the uh fast pushers from titan have been
called and found out but there's kenny s
with two and a third as well and a
[ __ ] unbelievable play from jenny
by 2014 kenny s was one of the biggest
names in cs go thanks to his unique
offering play style and his natural
talent
if he commits that bomb plan he has not
lived
he was the player everyone loved if you
played any cs go at all you want it to
be just like kenny but that kill coming
back to nbk opens up the plant potential
watch can he drop down hits exist up
close and it's get right versus kenny
what a tantalizing 1v1 spotted up oh
kenny that is unbelievable but the years
haven't been kind to kenny s after
becoming one of the most iconic players
in counter-strike and hitting milestones
that most pros can only dream of he
started to feel himself slipping and the
losses piled up
i know what people were expecting from
me
i know what i'm expecting from myself
but i could just could not be
his natural talent was still undeniable
but just talent wasn't going to cut it
anymore i'm known for being
also i mean for being good but also for
being pretty lazy
and relying on my talents only which i
did pretty much my entire career kenny s
was once on top of the world
now no one's even willing to roll the
dice on him so we had to ask
what happened to kenny x
kenny s was never your typical offer see
the op is a substantial investment for
any team it's expensive and it doesn't
give you a lot of money back for using
it you can't really use it up close and
if you missed your first shot you're
basically dead in a lot of situations
plus if you die and give a free op to
your opponents things get really bad
really fast
there's no way there's no way caden you
can't win pro league like this you can't
win pro league like this
no way
calling well above his years clearing
corners
you're an animal
heroic have done it and i just can't
believe it but while other players
shielded their precious ops from harm
like it was their first ever car kenny s
drove his like he stole it kenny he's
inside of this smoke he's trying to play
clever with this awp and he's got one no
no way kenny you gotta stop take it away
from him there's no way to shut him down
up close today even though uh avp mvp
players are known for being like holding
angles and weight
no i don't do that because it's kind of
boring
and i don't want to wait like one minute
on an angle i've been over aggressive
because because of that so i i cannot
push the limits of the weapon kenny s
defined aggro op play for a generation
of cs fans he was more than just a pro
he was a
finished off it comes kenny s
oh my god kenny s with three insane
kills kenny has his plays inspired pub
stars everywhere to slap a kenny s
sticker often a very expensive one on
their gun of choice kenny just had a
feel for the game a natural talent the
kind you can't teach but he did develop
it and kenny credits not only cs but
plenty of other games for teaching him
how to snipe i didn't learn quick
scoping on 1.6 i on on source i actually
learned it on
uh 1.6 day of defeat team fortress 2
that kind of games you know
this is where i actually learned to
place avp in the early days of cs go
kenny's aggressive approach just worked
he wasn't exactly running around like it
was death match but no one was using the
op like him oh my goodness so much
damage done hit by kenny s another
fright found and again kenny s
i i knew for a fact that first of all
they were scared of me
and the fact that people are scared of
you like it can happen when symbolism in
the clutch nowadays
uh it's much easier for you it gives you
more space and it gives you confidence
kenny's reign of terror was about to
come to an end though valve decided that
the mobile up close op style he invented
was not going to last the 2015 opner
slowed kenny's iconic style of play down
to a crawl for kenny it was an obstacle
but one he says he overcame quickly when
it comes to the mechanics of the game i
understand them very quickly so yes i
had
time to adapt i was picking and shooting
at walls at the beginning because it was
a bit too slow for me but i
you know after a few weeks i was fine
you know
and a few months after the nerf kenny
won the cluj-napoca major proving to
everyone that nerfing the op wasn't the
same as nerf and kenny s
so while the op nerf presented
difficulties kenny adjusted his talent
was still enough to keep him on top of
the world i remember like
being in on the zone really often at
that time like yeah the zone is a very
comfortable place to be and yeah i kind
of felt unstoppable at the time whatever
the team or the players i was playing
against cs doesn't change very often but
in the years following kenny's major win
things shifted a lot the meta got more
structured and set plays were created by
the best teams in the world
strategy has always been a part of the
equation in cs but the freewheeling
style of play that made kenny famous was
getting pushed out in favor of an even
more tactical approach kenny was so good
at cs go that his natural talent carried
him through the early years of the game
but talent only got him so far
as french cs entered another round of
roster shuffles a new powerhouse was
emerging in denmark astralis changed how
everyone approached the game thanks to
glaive's unique almost rigid playstyle
their first major the first time they're
in the finals and their first title will
find out because the action's on and
gary opens it up takes down bialy
already
there's the start four more kills and
they will have made it the full distance
snacks in an uncomfortable position he
goes down with the max 70 car make it
happen finally pasha coming in with the
refract but he's down the bomb has been
picked up by dupree they get the spray
kneel takes one and houses there and
astralis they win the first major
championship
16-14 against vertex bro
unbelievable
glaive's infamous strategy book quickly
filled up with strats and lineups and
astralis trophy case filled up just as
fast the astralis era showed cs players
everywhere the potential of structured
play and astralis opera device proved to
kenny s fans that a slow and steady
approach to opting could work too device
is even here to help out now
while it is good for one they give it
the respect to get back to the car that
might be their undoing the short play
now from twists oh device reads it in
with the flick burning alive and the
collateral in the flames the ace for
device and what a way to put up 14.
that is unheard of device doing them
dirty from the car meanwhile kenny s had
been swept up in constant french roster
shuffles until finally landing on g2
esports in 2017. while kenny's play was
as solid as ever his results after the
major win were uninspiring many were
hoping that his addition to g2 could
turn it into a true french super team
and sure they were big wins like the esl
pro league season 5 finals
one to go
and there it is
g2
from one and eight to something
absolutely great they pulled this back
and a 3-1 win convincing on inferno
but on g2 consistency was the issue for
both the team and kenny his natural
talent for cs go gave him an early
career start in a game that was still
being figured out but talent as kenny
describes it can be a double-edged sword
because things seems really easy
and natural
but at some point it also gives you
some kind of laziness you know
and
sometimes you you you do the best out of
it and i don't think i took the best out
of it g2 bombed out of the krakow major
group stage and kenny's enthusiasm was
slipping i gathered my team that day uh
before the tournament starts and i said
guys i'm gonna leave the team after the
tournament i'm gonna get the tournament
to think about it uh it happens that we
won the tournament i got mvp as well and
uh i was not even happy about it because
i had a really
crazy bad uh bad feeling mindset you
know maybe things would have been
different if kenny moved on from g2 but
he's stuck with the org and while he
doesn't regret his loyalty his choice
didn't exactly pay off in terms of
results
very slowly he might just need his match
right here moving into it misses the
shot will take about 20 damage from the
encounter oh and what is that molly
bounce what that goes up into the vents
for some reason there
kenny now gonna push up to the site but
was not ready to take the door on
mitsworld but now it's a one versus one
stewie versus kenny the smell of gunfire
and freedom in the air and stewie
picking up that kill and cloud9 are in
the semi-finals
oh my god what a story they shut down g2
almost flawlessly these places can be
molotov that's a different way to do it
forcing right now into the open the
transfer almost isn't is there that's
one more left for kenny but no kerrigan
does it and faze eliminate g2
and make it to playoffs
at the end of 2018 kenny s didn't make
hltv's list of the top 20 players in the
world for the first time since cs go
came out
while 2018 was a sad year for kenny s
2019 was a huge one for the french scene
because they got a new superstar opera
woo we shouldn't forget the fact that
they struggled massively on their t-side
as well they're anticipating banana from
the looks of the guy over here
that rings out first
he's had enough he's gonna keep going
through it he doesn't really care again
the appearance of a prodigy from his own
country seemed to have reinvigorated
kenny s who had the best year of his
career since the early days
a single stray bullet into the brickwork
would catch him but that doesn't stop
kenny
reads extra power perfectly and now she
goes for another he's got three only a
good refract there's kenny dropping the
bomb at all what a beautiful repeat goes
for another one and he's shutting it all
down bomb in the hands of kenny that
molotov's not going to land the smoke
was there neo would have gone down for
sure if he throws a molotov a second
later he gets the kill
what the hell is that we'll get it
he's back
but consistency was still lacking and
when esports entered the online era in
2020 it seemed to have an even bigger
impact on kenny than most and the
constant roster shuffles on g2 probably
weren't helping either even the addition
of superstar rifle nico didn't bring the
kind of results you'd expect from two of
the greatest cs go players of all time
but i think i should have just like
looked for a new challenge at some point
i don't know when
i don't know if it was after malmo if i
should have take a break at that time
other kind of things but i know that i'm
not the kind of people that can stay
passionated by one thing forever i
cannot it's impossible for me i played
cs for 20 years it's impossible for me
and so a year after the start of online
only play kenny s was benched this was
huge news one of the legends of
counter-strike was now inactive everyone
held their breath to see where kenny
would go next even though he was still
under contract to g2 tons of other teams
had to be sending him offers
right
right now in cs
not that much
even zero i would say because of the
situation and what i told you
that's sad
but i'm not surprised
it is what it is you know
and i want to give myself time
first of all if
if someone
uh some teams
might consider me at some point to give
me a new challenge new ambition after
years of underperforming no one wanted
the op god kenny's talent made him a
legend but his inability to put in the
hard work and develop himself in the new
style of cs led to him getting surpassed
by just about everyone and then
supplanted by a new prodigy but after
receiving no offers from professional cs
teams in 2020 in 2021 kenny finally did
something different
he started streaming
when you're lagging you have to flip
[Music]
the first
this is my first one
the move actually made a lot of sense
kenny has always been a larger than life
icon in cs and has a reputation for
being kind to his fans and supporters
then we started speaking the first time
we ever met kenny i should have said to
him bro can we get a picture
i've literally loved you for two years
without you knowing my name knowing my
existence
like he's the true bro he sat me down we
spoke for 50 minutes we played fifa
together like it was a super crazy
experience and streaming has been going
really well for kenny thousands of
viewers tune in to watch him play
whatever game he chooses to play that
day a return to cs isn't off the table
but the obvious question whether he'd
ever consider going pro-invalorant is
obviously out there right now i'm not
closing any doors that's what i'm seeing
i'm not taking decisions once again i
have time to think about things and i
have a list of party i have in my head
and
what i'm saying is that valuing is not
my priority right now but i enjoy
playing the game
and seeing that i close the door to
violence would be really stupid of me
kenny s impact on cs is undeniable sure
he may not be the winningest opera to
ever play the game he doesn't have the
most major wins or the most prize money
but in the hearts and minds of his fans
his legend is greater than any trophy
despite all the losses kenny inspired
people and those fans became pros who
inspired him in turn
he wasn't really practicing or like
watching demos trying to prove it i said
kenny i'm going to take you to a room
right now i'm going to because we had a
special program i said we're going to
watch demos together we spent four or
five hours watching demos and it was one
of the best nights of my life but really
it was crazy um then the next day he
dropped 30 kills and i take absolute 100
credit for that
um
see a man it was kenny's can is it going
inside and outside to serve and i love
him
so no matter what happens next whether
kenny goes back to cs switches to valor
inter keeps on streaming his true fans
will be lining up to see where he works
his op magic next
oh my god
cameras
man i'm kenneth let's go
you